SPEAKER: With an
increasing number
of heterogeneous services
across cloud and on-premises
environments,
customers are looking
for consistency in connectivity
and security operations.
Customers want to be able to
take a service-centric rather
than infrastructure-centric
approach to consuming cloud
services.
When consuming
services, some customers
wish to avoid exposure of their
data to the public internet
entirely because of
data security and policy
requirements.
Introducing Private Service
Connect from Google Cloud,
allowing you to connect
securely and effortlessly
to Google Cloud Services,
third-party partner services,
and company-owned
applications, helping
you to focus on consumption
of value-added services
regardless of the
underlying infrastructure.
With Private Service
Connect, SaaS providers
can deliver value-added
services faster,
providing a much better
experience for the customer.
Consumers can access services
directly and privately
over Google's backbone network.
Google operates an
extensive private network
that insulates customer traffic
from the public internet,
extending private transit to
the last mile for customers
who need or want this benefit.
Private Service Connect
creates service end points
in consumer VPCs that provide
private connectivity and policy
enforcement, allowing
you to easily connect
services across different
networks and organizations.
Services can be
consumed directly
in your virtual networks
without requiring middle boxes,
proxies, or other
complex configurations,
simplifying the management
of your cloud architectures.
Services consumed on
Private Service Connect
have the same high
performance attributes
as that of traffic
between virtual machines.
With this product,
we provide you
an end-to-end means
of connecting to
and managing services.
Take advantage of Google as
a service-centric network
solution, allowing you
to reach and satisfy
your clients' needs.
Private Service Connect
enables customers
to easily and securely
access services,
making it a win-win for both
producers and consumers.
Visit us at cloud.google.com
to learn more
about getting private access
to your services today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]